Blitz you know you don't want to take on
C6 you prefer lights over Bishops that's
I'm sure no he takes because it was a
blunder no one Kings he said there is
Bishop there's a bishop King B6 it's not
that Rook takes B7 is a possibility well
white wins that yeah it's a pawn like
this
it's an illegal move like a tree it's
enough that's incredible what has
happened what has happened a custom loss
in this case I'm not sure I'm not sure
it's double illegal if you know he have
played an illegal move
Carlson should stop the clock if he
plays another move that means it's
illegal
yeah
won the game like this you mean yes I
think I think that's incredible oh my
God that's really incredible